wow you're a charmer thank you have you
thought about how you're going to
propose maybe she should go in another
room I want to hear how you're going to
do it uh I have an idea is it like super
elaborate
I've gone back and forth on it um I just
know that I want to make it something
that she'll remember but I also most
importantly want it to it could be
terrible yeah and I promise you she'll
remember it and you know what that's
still on my radar
you know what's so funny it was during
the World of Color if you guys ever done
the World of Color yeah done the World
of Color watched it oh uh yes so we
watched the World of Color
go ahead
go ahead we watch the World of Color and
uh don't come in I'm doing the World of
Color
and uh the Aladdin song came on I was
like I gotta do it to this one I'm her
Aladdin
and uh
I like corny I like flipped her around
and looked at it flipped her around I
was holding her like this man like
holding like a real man dog I was like I
was like look at these cars I flipped
her around and then I flipped her around
and the funny part is I looked at her
and immediately when I saw her and I was
gonna say it I realized this was gonna
be the last time I said I love you for
the first time and so I choked up
I choked up and I couldn't I couldn't
say it I got choked and I got so choked
up I turned her back around flipped her
over
and then I was like she was so dizzy
with a World of Color and the flipping
a beautiful memory that I had well
you're not you're not describing it
beautifully go ahead and then I flipped
her back and I knew I had to explain why
I just [__] turned her back and forth
wow so I took her hand and I I put it on
my heart I go you feel that beating no
oh no I go no nervous because we have
any really corny romantic music that can
play animation to this we should do an
animation yeah until she screams stop
but we're doing the World of Color
definitely really uh free non-licensed
romantic music will get you to tell the
story again Kenny like a Kenny G type of
thing yeah I got you I'll get into
character okay we'll do it we'll get it
do we have it do we have any of this
royalty free romantic music royalty free
romantic music I love that we could do
it in post no no I want the real thing
yeah [__] uncomfortable it would be
for me to try to act serious with no
music yeah
searching for music for your next video
yes yes yes we are Kyle doesn't like the
public watching him work that's oh here
we go is that it yeah is that free it
says it is okay here we go so
go ahead you're watching World of Color
let him set the scene here we are go
ahead
[Music]
it's her birthday
was it it was interrupt me again
[Music]
I can't work like this I'm sorry I'm
sorry my daughter ruins the mood
it was her birthday
we already went to Vegas and had a
beautiful getaway
and I knew
that I had something very special to
tell this woman
in what place can I tell her such happy
news besides the happiest place
in the [__] world
and while we're at the most beautiful
place in the world
I knew I had to take her somewhere
that's more colorful than the rainbow
itself
a place
where dreams really do come true
and so while our song was playing in the
wind with the water and all of these
beautiful elements
I thought I was so ready
to let the love of my life know that I
I love her
so I I crapped her shoulders I grabbed
it
I spun her around
I couldn't believe it I was numb my
tongue was struck my nerves were shot my
gut was still unhealthy from gluten
so I flipped her back
and when I flipped her back around I had
to make sure she knew why
I was making her dizzy
so I took her hands I placed it on my
chest
it was beating
the drums were louder than the music
itself
and I let her know
baby
baby I love you
I love you I love you I [__] love you
yeah that's my [__] right there bro wow
that's right wow
wow
oh my God that was amazing oh my God got
you tingly huh oh that is so much better
than what my husband did
what did he do how did he say he loved
you for the first time we were in Miami
at Ultra and we were drunk that's all
you have to say he didn't remember the
next time
no way yeah because then I said it back
the next morning he was like whoa and I
was like you said it first he goes no I
didn't talk about an ultra shot
[Music]